hey youtubers it's Charlie happy weekend
so a lot of you had a bunch of arrow
questions about League of Assassins as
well as a Suicide Squad Rashad ghoul
even Stephen Amell being in the Justice
League so I picked 10 of your questions
to answer in this video also heads up if
you didn't see already i'm doing videos
for days of future past and Captain
America Winter Soldier trailers tomorrow
I don't know if I have time to do more
super movie trailers than that but be
sure to subscribe to get those they're
gonna be really cool so everybody grab
your mirakuru cocktails let's get going
I wish this made me strong like mirakuru
it only makes me think I'm strong so
question number one resin Suvari asks
who else will join The Suicide Squad
this season or is it possible that
Amanda already recruited some other
people so I don't think we're gonna see
them again till season 3 and when they
do come back it'll still be a really
small squad their product on a cast a
bunch of other people I'm hoping that
cheetah comes next because it'd be nice
to have another female super on the show
question number two Ian rashaun masks do
you think the mirakuru derived from the
Lazarus Pit seeing as how they both
share some similar properties and side
effects no I don't think so i think that
the mirakuru is closer to venom just
because they both drive people crazy i
would say the other thing that it's
really close to is you know Marvel Super
Soldier Serum but in all honesty it's
like a less crazy version of the venom
question number 3 Kenny Miranda 97 asks
will they introduce Slade's daughter so
you're talking about ravager they
haven't mentioned her I think since
season one at least his daughter they
haven't said the name ravager obviously
but they did mention Jericho in the last
episode so I think if someone comes on
first it would be Jericho and probably
not till season three but that would be
a really awesome storyline for Slade
question number four adam norrish and
asks what are their main DC supers do
you think arrow will have honestly i
don't think any other major superheroes
are gonna come on the show it's Stephen
Amell show so nobody's going to come on
that's a bigger actor than him or a
bigger character than green arrow with
the exception of flash and that's just
because they're launching a flash show
this year but you will see though is
flash and arrow people kind of bounce
off of each other shows at least in a
few cameos during that first season
question number 5 taken Master 87 asks
do you think by the end of season 2 or
the beginning of season 3 will ever see
ray shaw ghoul no I actually think Nyssa
al Ghul is kind of meant to fill that
hole they promote her so hard I think
they just want us to put all of our
attention on to her I don't think she's
gonna die this season I think she's
gonna get like the Grundy end you know
it's like you'll see them lying there
but you know they won't be confirmed
dead so they could always come back in
the future question number six Isaiah's
muzzle riego asks do you think the flash
TV show is going to introduce different
flashes like Wally West or Kid Flash and
when is it going to start so i actually
think that's going to start in the fall
but i don't think they're gonna have any
other flash besides the barry allen
flash and when they do have another
flash it'll probably just be you know
like the reverse flash so he's probably
gonna come on anytime soon though
question number 7 Henry LH asks did you
notice the guy that left the bar just
after Laurel did do you think he was a
member of the League of Assassins I
actually kind of think that he was just
a stalker person and thats Sarah who was
back at laurels apartment will end up
kicking his butt question number 8
Elizabeth 90 asks do you think that
Slade will make Oliver relive the
scenario of shadows death only this time
with Laurel and Sara you're talking
about in present day so careful for
potential spoilers in my answer cuz
that's actually a really good question
so in theory if he does do that then yes
the writers have said that they're
pushing Laurel towards the Black Canary
character but I didn't think she was
going to get there that fast I think
this season she's still going to be
regular Laurel it's totally possible
though based on what you suggested that
that could be how she becomes Black
Canary though you know Sarah dies so
there is no more canary so someone has
to fill in the hole question number 9
Jason cheeseball asks is Amanda Waller
good or bad it's kind of hard to tell so
Amanda Waller works for the government
so you should think of her is like a
shot gun that just shoots superheroes
and supervillains and problems and hopes
that they solve them or die trying so
she's kind of ambiguous that's part of
the appeal of the character is that
she's not really bad and she's not
really good question number 10 named
Harper asks do you think that Thea could
go to the dark side after learning who
her biological father is so I think that
by the end of the season you know all
the normal character relationships will
be resolved but I do think the League of
Assassins could dangle phia you know
like put her life in danger to bring
Malcolm out so in all likelihood she
will probably find out but it'll apply
be because she gets kidnapped and her
life is threatened alright and one more
bonus question mob master asks do you
think that Batman and Superman will be
mentioned or make cameos in the show and
do you think that the future Justice
League movie will include a new Oliver
Queen or Stephen Amell so definitely no
on the superman/batman they're way too
big to be on the show it would overpower
Stephen Amell it's his show
like I said earlier with respect to
Justice League Stephen Amell himself
actually went on his facebook page and
said absolutely not I have not been
approached about ain't justice league
movie in all likelihood the Justice
League movie will be like a Trinity
movie it'll just be batman superman
wonder woman and they just won't have
the green arrow in it don't get bummed
though because Stephen Amell also said
that he was totally down to make an
arrow movie that plywood until after the
show goes off the air which I'm not
expecting to happen for several seasons
hint hint I'm expecting at least five
seasons maybe even seven thank you so
much you guys for so many questions this
is a lot of fun hopefully I answer some
of your bigger questions don't forget
Nyssa al Ghul is coming next week it's
going to be totally awesome and a whole
bunch of super bowl trailer is coming
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
everything right now click here to get
last week's episode of arrow and click
here to learn all about Jesse Eisenberg
becoming Lex Luthor people had some very
interesting opinions about that it was a
lot of fun to talk about thank you so
much watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives